c'est la première fois que mélanie joly
met les pieds en ukraine et comme
baptême c'en est tout un à l'instar de
plusieurs filles qui ont déjà ou qui
prévoient dépêché d'urgence leur
diplomate en chef à kiev ministre est en
mission de solidarité comme il y aura
deux femmes dans un pays qui au dire de
l'otan pourraient être attaquées à tout
moment par la russie le canada tenait à
réitérer son appui indéfectible avec
c'est sûr qu'on est extrêmement
préoccupée par le fait qu' il n'y a plus
de 100 soldats aux frontières de l'écran
et donc dans les circonstances on prend
la menace russe très au sérieux le
risque d'une attaque russe s'est à ce
point réel selon le temps qu ottawa à
vis désormais ses citoyens d'éviter tout
voyage non essentiel en ukraine si pour
la majorité des ukrainiens et la vie
continue un peu comme si de rien n'était
les autorités elles se préparent au pire
en remettant en état de vieux abri
souterrain qui remontent à l'époque de
la guerre froide
aujourd'hui c'est contre une attaque de
l'ancienne mère patrie qui pourrait
servir
et juste au cas où depuis l'automne des
centaines de civils se sont enrôlés
comme réserver place et membre d'une des
130 nouvelles brigades de territoire
créé pour épauler l'armée en cas d'une
guerre contre la russie
l'épi le temps ne se battront pas pour
nous c'est clair dit il conclu devant
être prêts à nous défendre seul il
fallait s'y attendre le premier ministre
de l'ukraine a profité de la visite de
mélanie joly pour plaider sa cause en
privé ukraine demande de l'équipement et
des armes à ses partenaires ce à quoi le
canada ne ferme plus la porte est donc
votre soi que pour nous c'est important
de faire notre part dans les
circonstances
mais la contribution centrale du canada
la défense de l'ukraine demeure la
mission unifiée 200 soldats canadiens
qui à longueur d'année en train de
l'armée ukrainienne une mission que
mélanie joly ira visiter demain et qui
sera sûrement renouvelée au printemps et
de tous les avis de le temps c'est sûr
le canada que l'ukraine toujours
comptait le plus pour défendre son
éventuelle adhésion à l'alliance nous
croyons que le crâne devrait être en
mesure de joint de temps en même temps
il doit avoir des réformes démocratiques
qui ont lieu ici
ni qu'on soit encore loin du jour où ça
se concrétisera
la russie exige la garantie médias que
ça n'arrivera jamais
le porte parole du président de l'avenir
poutine s'est défendu de fabriquer un
prétexte pour envahir son voisin
la russie fait par la riposte si elle
n'obtient pas ce qu'elle vit ici tamar
altérer ce coup radio-canada moscou